what's going on guys this is rob and as
promised we are going to do a video on
the origin and powers of the watcher
really uwatu the watcher but it also
applies to all the watchers so what's
the origin of this guide all right the
origin of the watcher can be found in
three different locations the first one
is in tales of suspense vol 1 issue
number 53 the second one is in fantastic
four volume one issue number 13 which is
technically when he first appeared and
the second one is an original sin issue
number zero which is a crossover event
that marvel did some number of years ago
now the way these three stories all kind
of come together and give us the origin
of the watcher is that at some point
along the line in the early days of the
universe the race that we know is the
watchers came into existence now here's
a murky thing about the early days of
the universe in mobile comics even in
their own anthology series a history of
the marvel universe which was basically
a comic book story that was told i'd
like to believe in response to the video
anthology series that i made what it
basically does is not give us any real
definitive answers it just says once
upon a time the watchers existed and
that's basically it in marvel comics
when it comes to the early days of the
universe not a lot of information is
given there if you guys recall tanelier
tavon the collector from the marvel
cinematic universe or the grand master
from thor 3 ragnarok those guys are only
a couple of them but you have a group
called the elders of the universe
they're kind of a loose brotherhood and
the only thing they really share is that
they are the last surviving members of
their respective races which had
basically died out somewhere along the
line and so you don't really get a lot
of information there the watchers really
aren't that different from that but we
do get a little more info than we do in
comparison to like the elders what we
ended up learning is that in the early
days of their society they had become
super advanced technologically right
they had achieved like interstellar
travel and all kinds of stuff and so
they saw themselves as almost kind of
like this sort of shepherd for the
progression of the universe and the
first thing they believe they should do
is share their technology with the
universe and so they ended up coming
across a race called the proselytians
which i know it sounds like a weird name
hey comic books and they ended up giving
them the gift of atomic energy now for
time this race had a golden age where
they achieved all kinds of incredible
feats right all kinds of technological
achievements and then they did exactly
what you would expect them to do which
is probably what we as humanity would
end up doing they destroyed themselves
in a nuclear war
and so because of this the watchers
basically said no hands off now this was
not an immediate overnight thing instead
it happened over the course of time and
it was spearheaded by the father of
watching the watcher a man named icor
now the idea behind this is that i-corps
came to this realization that the only
way for the watchers to really function
in the universe given the catastrophic
failure of the race insofar as how the
proselytes had destroyed themselves
based on the gift of atomic energy is to
basically retreat to walk away from
everything and so i core essentially
drafted a kind of legislation or an
agreement among all the watchers that
they would no longer get involved in any
of the affairs of anybody in the cosmos
instead they would just watch and they
would chronicle now the son of ichor
uwatu of course asked the most logical
question what happens if a threat
emerges that could destroy the universe
which includes us and the response and
the agreement that was struck among the
watchers is it doesn't matter we're not
going to get involved we are not going
to have any involvement in this
whatsoever and that was the standard of
the watchers for quite some time now as
most of you guys know who watched the
watcher basically betrayed that when he
warned the fantastic four that galactus
was coming and that kind of set him on
the course of becoming more involved in
the affairs of people on earth now as
far as the powers of the watcher go they
are immense but because of his policy of
non-intervention you almost never get to
see them but over the course of marvel
comics they have given us several issues
story arcs things like that that really
help to solidify what the power of the
watcher is and these these kind of
instances or displays can be found in
really four major comic books right so
the first two comics come in the form of
fantastic four volume one issues 48 and
400. the third one here is strange tales
134 and the last one is uncanny x-men
issue number 203 now these are not the
only times you see the watcher uses
powers you see it other times as well
but by and large all the other
appearances that you see of him using
his powers in marvel comics are either
just reiterations of what you see in
these four comics or some of the things
that are mentioned in these four comics
actually being shown in those other
comic books but these are really the
main four that really tell you what the
watcher is capable of the important
thing is among those four comics that i
listed you end up learning things like
in strange tales the watcher can time
travel to any point in the past present
or future even the tva would be foolish
to challenge the watcher right that'd be
a fool's errand because all the watcher
would have to do is wipe them out of
existence why because in fantastic four
volume one issue number 400 it was
established that the watcher has vast
control over the cosmic energies that
exist in the marvel universe so much so
that he can actually challenge galactus
now what does that mean galactus is a
primal force of energy right he is
literally just energy given form and
just coalesces and literally travels
around the universe destroying worlds to
satiate his energy but the watcher much
like galactus even the celestials and
really like a lot of the cosmic entities
can use his control over cosmic energy
to do seemingly anything he wants to he
can create life he can destroy life he
can give people powers he can take
powers away he can do all kinds of stuff
if you can imagine it it can be done and
it's an immense amount of power to have
now fantastic four volume one issue
number 48 kind of going out of order of
the comics here but it doesn't really
matter what this established is that the
watcher has telepathy on a cosmic scale
now here's the funny thing about
telepathy and marvel comics telepathy
exists on a graduated scale in marvel
comics at the end of the day telepathy
is all basically the same the only
differentiation between one telepath and
another is how extensive their reach is
given their telepathic powers so if you
take for example somebody who's like a
base level telepath there's nothing
special about them they can read surface
thoughts right they can read whatever
you happen to be thinking at the time
which is man i really need to go to the
grocery store or did i leave the coffee
pot on somebody like professor x the
leader of the x-men is way more powerful
than that he can read subconscious
thoughts he can control your thoughts he
can actually make you believe that
something you think is your own genuine
thought so inception i guess he can do
all kinds of cool stuff now look at
somebody like the watcher his ability to
have telepathy on a universal scale
cosmic telepathy basically means he can
read and control the minds of everybody
across the cosmos at the same time
there's there's no real limit to what he
can do as far as how the mind works by
all standards of measurement he's a
walking talking mind stone right of the
infinity stones he's a walking talking
mind stone now there are some caveats
here a person who is a sufficiently
powerful telepath or even a cosmic
entity themselves can resist the
influence of the watcher take for
example jean grey jean grey under any
normal circumstance is not powerful
enough to resist the watcher but when
she became the phoenix the phoenix left
kind of a portion of its power with her
albeit she wasn't as powerful as she had
previously been but that increased her
telepathic abilities they were already
quite formidable but all that did was
boost them even higher so somebody like
the watcher could try to scan the mind
of jean grey and she could block him
right now other cosmic entities can do
the same thing galactus eternity
infinity eon master order lord chaos ego
the living planet these guys out there
can literally just block the telepathic
power of the watcher and keep the
watcher from being able to read their
minds but lastly and this is really one
of the more interesting things here in
uncanny x-men vol 1 issue number 203 it
essentially established that the only
way a watcher can die is if they choose
to die that watchers are by all
standards of measurement immortal the
only way a watcher will die from causes
that are external in the sense of the
watcher doesn't want to die but it dies
anyway is if like the universe dies now
that was the standard for years for
years and years and years and years and
years that was the standard of marvel
comics there was no conceivable way to
kill the watcher because his durability
was just so extreme i mean sure a cosmic
entity could but for the average people
who exist out there in marvel comics
living on earth it just couldn't be done
it would take somebody like the marquee
of death or the molecule man owen reese
or like jean grey with the power of the
phoenix force or some immense being out
there with so much power that they're
basically a universal threat franklin
richards of the fantastic four right the
son of mr fantastic who can alter
reality he could destroy the watcher but
this all changed during the events of
original sin and the reason why is
because original sin introduced this
idea that the old white guy nick fury
who you may or may not know anything
about there was actually a movie with
david hasselhoff when he played that
version of nick fury
your first inclination might be to write
it off as being ridiculous that movie is
actually amazing
i love that movie but nonetheless it was
revealed that that version of nick fury
had actually been operating as quote
unquote the man on the wall that
essentially he was protecting the earth
from all kinds of various threats don't
really know why marvel did that but the
important thing is nick fury killed the
watcher and this basically solidified
the watcher could be killed with
conventional weaponry if it was powerful
enough this totally changed everything
in terms of the watcher's immortality
and more recently the watcher came back
but the important thing is that as far
as his powers go he's exactly what you
think of when you think of a cosmic
entity this guy can create life destroy
life he can time travel back and forth
through time he can read and control the
minds of anybody across the universe or
everybody across the universe at the
same time with the exception of those
that can rival his own telepathic
capabilities the guy's an absolute host
but you never see him do any of that
because of its policy of
non-intervention which really begs the
question if the watcher got pissed off
enough what would happen to anybody who
made him mad he'd probably just turn him
into sludge i have no idea but with that
being said guys hopefully you found this
video interesting let me know down in
the comment section if you want to see
more origins of powers videos of not
just comic book characters but just
other characters in general let me know
what you guys think and i will catch you
all later
peace